a bipartisan group of senators is
pushing for reforms to combat sexual
misconduct in the military and in
Congress this morning New York
Democratic senator Kirsten Gillibrand is
reintroducing the military justice
Improvement Act it seeks to
professionalize how the military
prosecutes sexual assault
senator Gillibrand yesterday introduced
the me to Congress act she says too many
people are not taking the problem of
sexual harassment in Congress seriously
Gillibrand joins us from Capitol Hill
center - good morning good morning how
pervasive is the problem on Capitol Hill
and what do you think can be done to
stop it
I think the problem is pervasive and
what we have right now is the process
that's opaque difficult to navigate and
most survivors don't even know where to
report so our bill is going to change
all that make it transparent make it
more accountable and will actually have
a survey so every person who works here
can fill out a Climate Survey about
whether they feel safe whether they've
been harassed if so did they report if
not why not
Senate Speaker Ryan will introduce a
bill in the house will they be different
bills I don't know what his bill will
say but it's more than just having
training he said he wants to do training
that's not enough we need training 1 but
we also need to change the process so
that it's possible for someone to get
justice today if you have someone
harassing you at your office you'll have
to go through a mediation process for
months before you can even report your
case that is not something that's
conducive to people reporting or ending
harassment in the workplace
congresswoman Speier testified the other
day that there are two current members
of Congress one Democrat and Republican
who have engaged in this kind of
behavior but she did not name them do
you think they should be named well
that's up to the survivors a survivor
might not want to have to be in the
middle of a story for the next X number
of months she might want to continue
with her career she may might not want
to be discriminated against or somehow
retaliated against so the way I've
written my bill is to make sure the
survivor has the choice about whether or
not she wants to take the issue public
or he because right now they don't even
have that option they have to fight they
have to actually sign an agreement to
not disclose what happened to them Mitch
McConnell and others have floated the
idea of having Jeff Sessions serve as a
write-in candidate
his old seat in the Senate let me ask
you whether or not you would agree with
that and would you support that and if
it were between Jeff Sessions and Wymore
who would you rather serve within the
Senate well there's a great candidate
who's running on the Democratic line who
I support but from a Republican
standpoint because obviously we know
that the Republican is the front-runner
there if I had to choose a Republican
right and I would pick Luther strange so
you are not in favor of Jeff Sessions
serving as a write-in I just gave you my
answer if Senator Moore is elected do
you think he should be seated no I would
vote against him being seated actually
all right senator can you talk about
your military justice Improvement Act
how will it reduce or reduce or
eliminate sexual assaults how would it
work exactly
so the problem today is that every
Secretary of Defense for the last 20
years has said zero tolerance for sexual
assault the military but in fact last
year there over 15,000 cases estimated
and so what we have is a huge problem
where survivors don't necessarily feel
comfortable coming forward because last
year 59 percent who did reported that
they were retaliated against for doing
so and so what we have to do is change
the dynamic
we don't want commanders making the
decisions about which cases have to go
forward to trial in which cases don't
because those commanders are neither
lawyers nor prosecutors nor trained and
may well have biases so we need
transparency and accountability and so
the way the bill is written is we want
the decision to be made by trained
military prosecutors who have no bias
and who can make the decision based on
what does the evidence say and what we
have right now is a system where very
few cases are going forward to trial
even fewer ending in conviction the
conviction rate and the prosecution rate
have gone down in the last year it's a
problem so we need a military justice
system that is worthy of the sacrifice
that these men and women are making
every day for our country so senator are
you and Senator Claire McCaskill on the
same page on this senator McCaskill and
I have put forward
dozens of reforms that have already
passed into law but all of them have
really not dented the problem they
really are incremental reforms efforts
that haven't made a difference in how
many people are willing to come forward
and how many people are willing
to have their cases be prosecuted and
then how many cases will be prosecuted
and so what we need to do is have a
system that is more professional one
where people can have faith in the
system today they have less faith in the
system the percentage of people who are
reporting openly has gone down
we need that to go up and we need the
number of cases actually going to trial
and ending in conviction to go up we're
going in the wrong direction all right
senator Gillibrand always good to see
you thank you so much for taking the
time this morning